Wow das universum ist ganz anders als wir bisher
Gedacht haben die untersuchungen um die es in diesem video geht ist absolut spektakulär und hat es in sich die konsequenzen sind
gigantisch im wahrsten sinne des wortes ich sage nur
Außerirdisches leben und dunkle materie wie was wo wie ist die lage
Im kosmos jetzt sind links und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja ihr habt es gesehen hier hinten in der deko hat sich schon was getan unter den letzten wieder mehr viele geschrieben
Mach mal was anders hier fängt sein und wenn er selber ideen für fotos. Habt postet mir die links unten in den kommentaren
Ja ein internationales forschungsteam wollte mal genauer wissen wie viele sterne von welcher größe so in einer galaxie entstehen bei uns in der
Milchstraße ist der prozess ja so ziemlich abgeschlossen bei uns entstehen im jahr sterne mit einer gesamtmasse von
unserer sonne das ist in kosmischen maßstäben
so ziemlich eigentlich gar nichts in der magellanschen wolke ist das etwas anders
Im dortigen sterne bildungssektor, 30 dorados sind es
1000 mal mehr sonnenmassen die dort pro jahr entstehen und was da entsteht ist absolut spektakulär und wirft alles um denn es werden dort
vielmehr große
massereiche sterne
produziert als eigentlich bisher angenommen wurde große massereiche sterne
Sind nämlich eigentlich selten und so war es bisher schwierig zu bestimmen wie viel
Gesamtmasse sie im all haben in der 180 tausend
lichtjahre entfernten mal gelang schon wolke ist das eben anders in der aktiven stern wege werden sterne
Am laufenden band produziert und zwar besonders große die forscherinnen und forscher analysierten jetzt mit dem very large telescope der europäischen
südsternwarte
eso in chile die spektren der sterne aus denen sich die größe ableiten lässt und sie trauten ihren augen nicht zitat
Wir waren enorm überrascht als wir feststellten dass 30 dorado, so viel mehr massereiche sterne gebildet hat als erwartet
So erst autor fabian schneider von der university of oxford sie sind zwar immer noch seltener als kleinere sterne
Also wie unsere sonne aber sie machen einen deutlich größeren teil
Gesamtgewicht aus weil sie so viel schwerer sind ein beispiel ist
r136a1 der blaue riese wird auf achtung 300 sonnenmassen geschätzt und leuchtet noch mal achtung
8,7 millionen mal heller als die sonne ob sie bis noch vor ein paar jahren hatte man. Gedacht dass bei so
150 sonnenmassen schluss ist pustekuchen auch das war ein irrtum jetzt kommt s und das wirft alles um zitat
unsere ergebnisse legen nahe dass der größte anteil der gesamten stern masse nicht in massearmen sternen steckt erklärt mitautor
Chris evans vom rollator in edinburgh die ergebnisse sind absolut und werfen sie bedeuten dass es rund
70 prozent mehr super novell gibt als bisher angenommen denn dazu
Entwickeln sich diese sterne unter anderem das würde bedeuten dass dreimal so viele schwere elemente produziert würden als bisher vermutet das sind die elemente
Die zum leben nötig sind sauerstoff zum beispiel oder eisen zitat
unsere ergebnisse haben damit weitreichende bedeutung für unser gesamtes
verständnis des kosmos das sagt schneider und eines finde ich absolut sensationell da viele dieser riesensterne zu schwarzen löchern
zusammenfallen vermuten die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler dass und jetzt bitte hinsetzen es dreimal
So viele schwarze löcher gibt als bisher gedacht
Ich weiß an dieser stelle nur auf die theorie hin dass die dunkle materie
Auf schwarzen löchern besteht und eben nicht aus einer neuen art teilchen mal überlegen wie wäre es wenn am ende herauskommt
das dunkle materie und dunkle energie lediglich
Hilfskonstruktionen waren um die wissenslücken der kosmologie zu stopfen ja es wäre ja nicht das erste mal in der geschichte
Der menschheit es würde mich nicht wundern wenn es solche
bahnbrechenden
absolut umwerfend
Erkenntnisse auch heute noch gibt es wird auf jeden fall
spannend dass die dunkle materie aus schwarzen löchern besteht die theorie
Habe ich übrigens in diesem video vorgestellt dafür drauf klicken wenn er sehen wollt
dunkle materie rätsel gelöst spielen schwarze löcher eine rolle wenn ihr weiter kein
Zu diesen themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran